Russia's invasion of Ukraine has
devastated the country but the full
scale of military activity has been hard
to assess
so Sandra ulvan solstad The Economist
senior data journalist came up with a
plan to penetrate the fog of War
I figured my comparative advantage would
be to look at the war from above
[Music]
one worry I had When The War Began was
that a lot of media Outlets were relying
on the same sources of information it's
pretty easy to see what's going on in
Kiev right now you have a lot of people
there you have a lot of reporters there
it is slightly harder to see what's
going on close to the front line on the
Ukrainian side it is way harder to know
what is going on on the Russian side and
especially deeply in Russian occupied
areas
I wanted an independent system A system
that was neutral consistent and that
could track the fighting without relying
on human input
firms is a satellite surveillance system
set up by NASA to track forest fires
however it tracks a lot of other fires
too
I set up a system that looks at this
forest fire data and tries to figure out
if it's really forest fires or any other
source of fire that would happen in
peacetime or if it's related to the
fighting I first said about constructing
what we call training data so this is
the data from normal years that the
model we use to sort of learn what is
supposed to be going on you need to go
back in time and find all sorts of other
data but once you have that you go into
the training stage and that's telling a
computer find all the patterns you can
in this data and in my case telling it
to do that 100 times
and then if you plot the abnormal
activity Trends start to appear this map
reveals areas where the fires are active
if you look at where the fires are most
concentrated we can see a hot spot on
the road to Kiev and the front line can
also be clearly observed
so the system isn't perfect for one
thing it can see through clouds which
are heavy especially in Winter the other
thing is that it's probabilistic
sometimes it will categorize a fire as
warrelated when it's actually not and
even more frequently it looked at fires
and say this could be a normal fire when
it's actually related to the war
the situation is unfolding rapidly our
system updates twice a day taking in the
latest data from the satellites and
processing it in real time
if you want to follow the war using our
tracker you can click on the link in the
top right corner
so before an advance you need what is
called shaping operations these are
operations which disrupt the enemy's
ability to respond to your attack this
can include things like attacking
logistic hubs ammo Depots and command
centers I've been monitoring it pretty
closely what I noticed starting around
the middle of May was that there was a
ramp up in war events or these fire
events in Russia held territories of
Ukraine
if you look for May 11th onwards the
data shows an increase in russian-held
areas and along the front line
[Music]
on June 5th I started to notice changes
in the data
the model is detecting operations
underway in several areas near the front
line from kimbern spit to the Belgard
border these include the area south of
Herson which is seen particularly
intense fire activity as has the front
lines south of saporation and the area
north and south of bakmuth
the data suggests the Ukrainian Army is
pushing forward a military bombardments
are escalating
the Fogo 4 is always with us but another
constant of conflict is fire I set up
this system so we could pierce the fog
of war and see what is going on on the
ground every day
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage of the war in Ukraine click
on the link and don't forget to
subscribe
foreign
[Music]